nestled in the himalayas in indian
administered kashmir the town of gulmarg
is one of asia's highest and largest key
resorts
it's also where rf khan first took up
his key polls
and now he's competing in two slalom
events at the olympics in beijing
skiing training i was trained by my
father for the first eight years he
taught me the basics the state and
national level champions also trained
here in gulmurg they inspired me and i
also learned by watching them eventually
i started training in europe and other
countries those experiences were great
for exposure and skill development
india has sent only 15 olympians in the
history of the winter games and has
never won a medal
khan is the only entrant this year
many of those keen to compete say
there's little money and no
internationally recognized federation to
support athletes
khan's training was funded by his father
who runs a ski shop his family and
friends also supported him
farhad nike is a national level
snowboarder who once dreamed of
competing at the olympics due to no
support from government and from the
private place i couldn't make it in
reality and i think this dream is gonna
die in goldberg only
as far as the infrastructure is
concerned we we snowboard here on a very
very basic infrastructure we don't have
any slopes for snowboarders no lift for
snowboarders
over the last two years hundreds of
enthusiasts have attended training camps
and competitions sponsored by the
government but the local sporting body
says more needs to be done to spot and
support budding talent
other countries are winning medals so
why not india kashmir has the best
assets in terms of snow we have slopes
and new equipment we request the
ministry to conduct international level
tournaments and coaching camps to boost
our youth there's no death of talent
here we will have more arif khans
khan hopes to break into the world's top
30 at the games his greater goal is to
inspire more people to take up the sport
but knows that getting the support
that's needed will be an uphill task
al jazeera new delhi